bonjour à tous merci de nous rejoindre
dans le kiosque votre magazine culturel
regardons tout de suite le sommaire de
notre édition du 6 au 18 décembre le
réseau des médiathèques de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et leurs
partenaires culturels vous invite à la
fête du conte une treizième édition
teinte et d'imaginaire de merveilleux et
deux moteurs et nous en parlerons dans
quelques instants avec nos invités en
concert à la batterie de guyancourt le 6
décembre féfé ancien membre du saïan
supa crew présente à nicolas gervais son
dernier album le charme des premiers
jours l'avant première du film la marche
était projeté dimanche à l'ugc en
présence notamment du réalisateur nabil
ben yadir et de l'inde et comédien jamel
debbouze un film en hommage aux trente
ans de la marche pour l'égalité et
contre le racisme
chaque semaine le septième art est mise
à l'honneur dans notre chronique
cinéphiles grégory pagano responsable de
l'espace philippe noiret
clayes-sous-bois nous livrera son coup
de coeur
alors qu'il soit merveilleux fantastique
de fait ou facétieux leconte qui tire
ses origines d'histoires populaires
transmise oralement est aujourd'hui
ancrée dans les traditions littéraires à
50 ans le réseau des médiathèques et
leurs partenaires organisent la
troisième édition du fait de la fête
pardon du compte et qui se tiendra donc
du 6 au 18 décembre nous en parlons ce
soir avec nos deux invités je commence
par vous laurence canton bon soir
l'histoire alors vous êtes
bibliothécaire pour le centre de
ressources des professionnels de
l'enfance est par ailleurs pilote du
projet fait du congo depuis 13 ans voilà
et en face de vous yoann hammam bonsoir
alors vous êtes le directeur de la ferme
de bel ébat à guyancourt alors vous vous
la ferme de bel va donc participants
fait à l'événement on en revient on en
reparle dans quelques instants vous nous
donnerez tous les détails alors tout
d'abord laurence je m'adresse à vous
voilà donc vous allez présenter pas
moins de 40 spectacles tout public des
tout petits jusqu'aux adultes alors
qu'elles sont cette année les nouveautés
puis les rendez vous incontournables
alors les nouveautés cette année on
revient fait c'est une nouveauté est à
la fois on revient à l'origine de la
fête du conte dès à présent c'est à dire
que l'on fait les comptes au mois de
décembre donc cette période de noël
merveilleux de cocooning de
rassemblements familiaux
voilà je sers des comptes que sur noël
non ce ne sera pas des comptes sur noël
ce sera plutôt des contes merveilleux
c'est du côté cocooning c'était vraiment
le côté se réchauffe et d'ailleurs on
n'a pas du tout envie de sortir parce
qu'ils mal à écouter d'abord mois donc
voilà c'est quand même plus agréable
ça va des tout petits avec des
spectacles aussi bien aimé chanter
danser pour des 18 à 12 en trois ans
comme pour les adultes
soirée d'inauguration
il ya une soirée d'une régulation qui
sera le 6 décembre qui sera qu'il
commencera par un contenant ces
démontrer qu'ils sont qui vont partir au
ciel il aimait vraiment et d'alerté donc
voilà léman prix on part du réel pour
arriver par un petit voire un gros
mensonge sans qu'on s'en aperçoive
on s'en aperçoit en fait juste dans la
période finale qui est souvent
humoristique on se rend compte que nous
a un petit peu mener en bateau donc
c'est drôle c'est drôle et à la fois on
ne sait jamais parce que des fois on
sait qu'il va ailleurs des menteries on
ne sait jamais quand est ce qu'on est
vraiment dans le réel quand on est
complètement dans l'imaginaire est-ce
que c'est pas aussi un peu salée compte
mais ça c'est un petit peu salée contre
mais quand on rentre dans le conte on
rende en mairie on rentre dans le il
était une fois donc il était une fois
c'est cet espace temps où tout est
permis on peut s'identifier aéro être
complètement misérable de manière
vraiment millionnaire être un pauvre
petit paysan est posée la superbe
princesse donc vraiment c'est un espace
où tout est permis et on le sait dès le
départ on va dire il était une fois et
on rentre dans cet univers la menterie
émana simplement traverser la rue et
puis la bombe d'un coup on a vu une
espèce de monstre est en fait est ce que
c'était un monstre voilà on peut jouer
là dessus nous ne le sera qu'à la fin un
stationnement trice à lachute baiser
lâcher donc là on va commencer par
démontrer qu'ils vont un petit peu
ponctué le spectacle d'inauguration
après il y aura vraiment des spectacles
de menteries qui seront vraiment
intitulé dans mon mensonge il ya enfin
bon et il y aura de temps en temps me
laissera dans les spectacles démontrer
donc la phobie un bien et tendre
l'oreille donc ce sera avec différents
partenaires on l'a dit alors j'avais
évoqué la ferme de bel ébat on aura une
illustration ce soir il ya également le
prisme le t elle prise la sphère de
mousseaux le théâtre de saint quentin la
ville de wazzan retenue qui prêtent
aussi des salles donc on a qu avec de
nombreux partenaires alors le mieux
c'est de renvoyer nos téléspectateurs à
la programmation parce que c'est une
programmation très riche très large donc
voilà le petit bandeau s'affiche le site
internet il médiathèque avec comme ça
donc toutes les dates où les lieux moi
j'ai envie que j'ai envie de savoir
exactement qu'est ce qu'un compte
finalement là vous l'avez un petit peu
évoqué le côté imaginaire le côté réel
on est amené dans une aventure
qu'est-ce-qui qu'est-ce qu'on attend en
fait d'un compte qu est ce qu est ce qui
est merveilleux
ils sont pas tous merveilleux on ne sont
pas tous nos beaux yeux
on attend d'être dans un autre univers
de s'identifier au héros au pluriel et
de pouvoir dépasser une situation qui
peut être pénible et c'est à travers ces
routes dont on s'identifie
on attend de nous transpose et juste par
le son de la voix par le par cette
communication dans un autre monde qui
n'est plus qui n'est plus le sien donc
voilà le héros permet de grandir le
héros permet de dire moi je suis capable
de jeu peut aussi y arriver et ça fait
du bien d'accord donc ce soit finalement
pour les enfants pour les enfants dont
les échos ont besoin de rêver voilà donc
là j'en profite pour parler d'un
spectacle qui va avoir lieu le 7
décembre à 11 heures un voisin
bretonneux organisé par la médiathèque
saint-exupéry qui seront des comptes
coca autour de la fontaine est réservé
pour les adultes d'accord
et dessous des fables de la fontaine les
pieds dessous des facs de la
cimenterie sans montrer les charges en
profite c'est pour dire que on a
toujours un public qui nous échappe un
petit peu et c'est le public des
adolescents et jeunes adolescents et à
partir du mois de janvier etienne qui va
être un petit peu notre bonne humeur
notre monteur professionnels vont
organiser des ateliers de montry avec
des classes de 6e et 5e et une
restitution qui se fera sous forme de
battle au mois de mai d'accord pour
passer noté on a pris note johan à vous
qui dirigez donc le théâtre de
guyancourt la ferme de bel ébat quelle
différence finalement lié entre un
compte et une représentation théâtrale
ce qu'on l'a vu il ya des contes
illustrés enfin que ce soit chanté et
dansé des marionnettes finalement quelle
est notre force c'est vrai que c'est une
question qui se pose depuis surtout
depuis les années 80 années où le comte
a commencé à investir les salles de
théâtre avant se poser - la question
puisque le compte avait toujours lieu en
dehors des théâtres aujourd'hui on a des
compteurs sur les scènes des théâtres
des théâtres de villes comme la ferme de
bel ébat comme des scènes nationales et
la différence fondamentale c'est que le
passeur le par là le compteur est un
passeur c'est un passeur d'histoires
donc ce n'est pas quelqu'un qui joue et
c'est quelqu'un qui raconte et donc la
différence mais il transmet donc il
n'est pas dans l'incarnation
il ne revêt pas les oripeaux d'un
personnage donc voilà c'est la
différence essentielle sinon il ya aussi
cette notion de l'adresse directe au
public ils ne parlent pas un autre
personnage il parle au public souvent
avec une part de liberté une part
d'improvisation le compteur c'est aussi
quelqu'un qui a un répertoire qui a
beaucoup d'histoire derrière lui qui est
capable comme ça à la demande d'embrayer
sur une histoire ou sur une autre
comédien oui il n'y a pas non plus cette
notion de nécessaire du parker qui a
chez le comédien le le compteur tisse un
peu ça c'est l'histoire avec ses propres
mots avec ses propres sensations du
moment moyenne liberté différentes et du
coup une écoute une approche très
différente ajustements laurence
peut-être vos piètres conteuse aussi
calé les quelles sont les qualités
requises dans un bon conteur il faut
être vraiment dans son histoire parce
que justement on va pouvoir trouver ses
propres mots et on vibre avec avec le
public c'est ce petit côté un petit peu
excitant quand on quand on raconte de
pouvoir répondre par rapport aux frais
son ensemble le public a et c'est un
petit peu comme ça qu'on va orienter
son histoire ça soit des tout petits
parce que bon je raconte énormément de
petits mais par et aux adolescents on va
sentir les on va sentir lésé vendus à
des les émotions il ya un petit côté
miroir on voit ce que le public ressent
par rapport à ce que vous dites et c'est
là on va travailler et justement être un
petit peu dans l'improvisation
raccourcir des choses ont rallongé parce
que les ensembles c'est là où ça fait du
bien donc il ya vraiment ce cette osmose
et ya vraiment une vraie interaction
enfin véritable attraction qui pas de
parker c'est possible mais l'histoire
est vraiment dans notre tête dans notre
corps très bien alors la ferme de bel
ébat vous organiser une journée donc
consacré aux contes c'est le 7 décembre
c'est dans le cadre de la fête du compte
pas moins de six spectacles seront
proposés différentes animations alors on
n'a pas beaucoup de temps donc je vais
un petit peu les mêlant c'est comme ça
et puis encore une fois on invite à
noter spectateurs à retrouver la
programmation donc ça démarre le matin
avec les tout petits dix-huit mois et le
réseau des médiathèques et christèle
pimenta don qui est une conteuse aussi
professionnel qui accueillera donc le
public un petit peu au gré des envies
ses centres 11h et 12h ou in type à la
carte voilà j'ai des comptes à la
demande c'est typiquement pas un
spectacle mais mais plusieurs comptes
qui peuvent être voilà qui seront dix à
différents endroits en fonction de l'âge
des spectateurs on sait pas qui viendra
et c'est durant c'est en entrée libre
entrée libre très bien ensuite à 14
heures christèle pimenta donc cette
conteuse professionnelle présentera son
spectacle rage de dents alors là c'est
dedans à l'intérieur j'en entends c'est
l'histoire d'une petite fille qui vit
les choses avec beaucoup d'émotion donc
14 heures pour ce spectacle 16 heures
c'est un duo 2 d'une conteuse et d'un
musicien donc voilà on à l'association
un petit peu illustré différemment ça
s'appelle le roi des corbeaux c'est un
conte surréaliste et loufoque et enfin
l'après midi l'après midi début de
soirée est donc là aussi ce sera
ponctuée diffus à plusieurs reprises
c'est des petits contes de dix minutes
alors là c'est une conteuse qui vient
avec sa caravane c'est ça et qui va
raconter qu est ce qu elle répond oui
ces prêts ling et para donc qui vient
déposer sa caravane sur la place de bel
ébat et qui raconte des histoires
qu'elle a collectées au fil des années
dans la région ile de france et voilà
c'est vraiment une manière de montrer
comment le conte contemporain peut
puiser son inspiration dans les récits
de vie et à partir d'une situation
singulière tendre vers l'universel c'est
ça c'est le chacun puisse se
l'approprier encore une fois alors je
vais très vite parce que malheureusement
on est vraiment pris par le temps je
suis désolé michèle nguyen donc
présentera également son spectacle vie
alors elle a reçu le molière 2011 donc
spectacle jeune public
on vous invite à voilà quelques images
donc elle raconte son enfance avec une
marionnette donc c'est assez poignant
c'est plein d'émotions et enfin dernier
spectacle
alors là c'est un conte thriller alors
c'est pas courant donc ça mérite
vraiment d'y aller pour pour se rendre
compte qu est ce que c'est que l'epr ça
s'appelle après ce sera toi alors voilà
toute l'intrigué est posée donc rendez
vous le 7 à 21h à la ferme de bel ébat
merci beaucoup à tous les deux je suis
désolé ça a été un petit peu un petit
peu bref sur la fin merci d'être venu
toute la soirée que programmation donc
sur réseau des médiathèques bougeait pas
nous on va retrouver tout de suite
nicolas gervais pour sa chronique
vendredi 6 décembre alors fait fait donc
c'est l'ancien membre du groupe saïan
supa crew sera en concert à la batterie
à guyancourt nicolas lé gervais la
rencontre est en écoute
second album intitulé le charme des
premiers jours un de la pia en octobre
et une belle tournée qui passera
notamment le 6 décembre par la batterie
à guyancourt aujourd'hui dans le kiosque
que nous recevons un ancien du saïan
supa crew qui a su se forger un style
musical bien à lui il s'agit de
c'est exactement ça par peur des hausses
toiture comprise et pin a comme un a
priori plutôt c
un
goal
oui exactement c'est ce que je voulais
tu as tout dit dans ce gala comme je
voulais plus de rappeler deux chansons
et je ne voulais pas qu'on puisse été
dissociées parce que c'est moi parce que
c'est ce que je voulais à ce moment là
parce que je suis un rappeur à la base
donc pourquoi l'enlever du rap et parce
que j'aime la chanson aussi quoi tu vois
donc pourquoi ne pas en mettre et
comment on fait ça on y va c'est tout
un peu
c'est plus fort que moi c'est comme ça
c'est que en tout cas pour cet album là
je ne voyais pas d'autre chose
à ce moment là j'avais pensé j'ai pas
envie de forcément d'être atypique pour
moi ce que je fais est complètement
normal en fait je te dis la vérité c'est
naturel mais voilà je sais en face de
moi que je vois que ça fait atypique
quoi parce que les ont six matches en
mai mais tu fais pas craint pays qui
sont bien quand même et tout alors mais
pourquoi ne fait pas que chanter enfin
bon
c'est limite c'était parler d'amour
voilà m'a parlé d'amour je viens de
citer c'est pas mon truc je veux dire à
la base ça pour moi c'est un truc de
lover quand
c'est pas mon truc je fais pas du r'n'b
quoi et l'âge avons vu je me disais je
commence à être vieux enfin vieux ça va
tranquille toujours là mais je suis plus
mûr on va dire voilà j'ai plus 20 ans
donc il ya des sujets que je permet
d'aborder ce soit l'amour perdu ou
l'amour de mes enfants tout simplement
exactement de garder l'amour toujours
intacte et aussi l'amour de cette france
qui n'est pas rendu parfois d'un morceau
que j'ai appelé gaulle comme ça il ya eu
après il ya aussi nous est un thème qui
nous parle de nous qui c'est juste un
thème ou disons je me pose des questions
et je me demande mes mais qui fait
toutes ces choses qui nous paraissent si
folle où ces mauvaises tu vois et
quelque part je fais partie de ces
personnes là qui font ces choses qui
nous paraissent six fois de si mauvaises
voilà et nous tous quelque part
à
je john
ad
j'ai accepté que je fais de la guitare
j'avoue j'ai accepté voilà je suis nul
en guitare attention je préfère prévenir
les gens parce que les gens vont croire
que j'avais croyait - non non non non
non c'est tel un gamin d'être comme ça
mais j'ai accepté que j'étais musicien
voilà tout ça pour dire ce à quoi et moi
ça me fait plaisir parce que je connais
rien au solfège j'ai commencé en sans
plomb les vinyles de mon père quoi et en
essayant de faire match et des choses
ensemble et maintenant je peux prendre
une guitare et jouer des choses
accompagner des gens quoi trop ça
merveilleux
quoi que je fasse on me retrouve ça ça
m'enrage donc ce soit dans cet album
dans le précédent ou dans le prochain on
retrouvera forcément quelque chose qui
dit à ségus fait quoi et j'essaye de
c'est ma couleur voilà c'est comme ça
mais j'essaie de la croûte de la
transposer sur autre chose à chaque fois
quoi là son prochain album j'ai envie de
prendre des risques et d'aller encore
vers l'autre par quoi toujours vert du
fait quoi mais musicalement d'essayer de
prendre un peu plus de risques
et tu joues
tout
jeu
des fouilles sur scène c'est dans le
public c'est sur scène c'est vous aussi
c'est ça le sur scène quoi moi j'ai
besoin d'eux d'avoir l'impression qu'on
est tous connectés ensemble quoi tu vois
pour s'attacher à la fête de l'huma vous
m'interrogez à la fête de l'huma
rarement ça doit être fait pour moi
défaite comme ça parce que je ne peux
pas faire plus humain que moi j'essaie
vraiment de ramener tout le monde est de
casser un délire quoi du genre attention
je suis la star vous êtes le public
j'essaye de dire à peu près là on est
ensemble on va peut-être passer qu'une
ensemble mais pour qu'on la passe
ensemble
tous
toi
jours
voilà pour ces faits et le charme eu des
premiers jours et si vous voulez
réserver vos places pour ce spectacle
n'oubliez pas que ce que la billetterie
sur le
www.cadets.ca qui point fr et maintenant
on retrouve celle qui a su garder le
charme des premiers jours j'ai nommé
aurélia
quel charmeur nicolas à la semaine
prochaine passant tout de suite à notre
chronique cinéphiles
l'avant première du film la marche était
projeté à l'ugc saint-quentin où c'était
dimanche en présence notamment du
réalisateur nabil ben yadir et de l'inde
et comédien jamel debbouze nous les
avons rencontrés retour sur un film
hommage aux trente ans de la marche
contre le racisme et pour l'égalité
dimanche lui j'essaie de 50 ans
accueillaient jamel debbouze trappistes
d'origine et l'équipe du film la marche
à l'occasion d'une projection en avant
première un long métrage librement
inspiré de la marche pour l'égalité et
contre le racisme mouvement qui trente
ans plus tôt dénoncé les conditions des
immigrés en france une marche pacifiste
parti de marseille de 15 octobre 1983
pour rejoindre paris avec un cortège de
cent mille personnes en décembre bien
que la sortie du film soulève au regard
de l'actualité la question du sens de la
marche aujourd'hui pour l'équipe de
tournage il s'agit surtout de retracer
des faits historiques
c'est une histoire assez extraordinaire
de voir des jeunes aspiré par le bandit
qui décide d'organiser une marche non
violente pour l'égalité et contre le
racisme ça résonne mais c'est avant tout
un sujet cinématographique en or qui
plus est une histoire vraie donc je
pense que malheureusement ou
heureusement pour certains les agents
des impôts cordes et on se dit que ce
film a besoin d'être vu maintenant et on
sent en dessous voilà on est flatté pour
sa mémé
mais c'est avant tout une grande
histoire cinématographique
un hommage aux marcheurs et l'ambiance
qui régnait que les comédiens sont fiers
de présenter
peu de gens connaissent la marche il ya
eu un sondage ya pas longtemps qu'ils
disaient que 80 entre 80 et 90% des
jeunes n'était pas au courant de cette
marche donc si grâce à ce film on peut
on peut rendre hommage déjà aux vrais
marcheurs et puis leur fournir surtout
un beau film
on est très fiable d'abord comme
comédien évidemment jouer genre de
partitions - joue un toxico roublard ça
m'était jamais arrivé j'en prenais ses
plats
et et défendre ce genre d'idée de propos
qui rassemble la france raconter cette
histoire d'amour pour la france à
travers cette jeunesse c'était pour moi
c'est vraiment une chance c'était un
super film très très bien et très
émouvant aussi par rapport à ce que ces
marcheurs à l'époque ont vécu parce
qu'ils ont vécu quand même des mauvaises
choses par là par les français il faut
le dire parfois que ça se reproduise
sortie nationale du film le 27 novembre
la justice n'est pas un hacker
elle est le fruit de leur révolte
la chronique signifie il vous le savez
c'est aussi l'occasion d'entendre un
professionnel nous donner son coup de
coeur de la semaine et aujourd'hui c'est
au tour de grégory pagano responsable de
l'espace philippe lauret aux
clayes-sous-bois
aujourd'hui j'ai envie de vous parler
d'un film d'animation un film qui a été
primé au festival d'annecy en 2013 un
festival qui fait référence en la
matière il s'agit de maman est en
amérique elle a rencontré buffalo bill
un très beau film très émouvant
également puisque il raconte la vie d'un
petit garçon de six ans qui cherche un
peu sa maman et qui pensent qu'elle est
en voyage mais malheureusement va rendre
compte que c'est pas le cas et que c'est
une situation un peu plus compliqué et
c'est donc cette
ce problème du deuil qui va être traité
dans le film avec beaucoup d'émotion
non
ce film a été adapté d'une bande
dessinée qui avait eu également un joli
succès et c'est la preuve aussi que les
films d'animation ne sont pas que pour
les enfants même si je dis si c'est très
bien le voir en famille et d'être là
avec les enfants pour pouvoir leur
expliquer un petit peu ce qui se passe
mais c'est aussi un film que les adultes
auront beaucoup de plaisir à voir non
seulement parce que le sujet est très
fort et très émouvant mais aussi parce
que c'est un film qui est plein de
nostalgie plein de poésie et plein
d'humour aussi avec une histoire qui se
passe dans les années 70 et donc qui
nous rappellera sûrement pour beaucoup
d'entre nous des souvenirs d'enfance
maman est en amérique elle a rencontré
buffalo bills c'est cette semaine à
l'espace friche noir
alors voici à présent quelques dates de
quelques idées de sorties ces prochains
jours alors on démarre avec une soirée
de concerts hip hop à la batterie donc
de guyancourt c'est vendredi à 20h30
c'est une programmation qui s'inscrit
dans le cadre des pulsations urbaines et
des 30 ans du hip hop à saint quentin en
yvelines est toujours dans le hip hop
mais cette fois-ci de la danse deux
moments de danse ont proposé par la
compagnie mythique saint-quentinoise
black blanc beur alors avec jeu si je
t'aime donc c'est une création qui a
déjà fait le tour du monde et paradoxe
qui elle est proposée par les baies 3
juniors donc la relève est ainsi assurée
et c'est à la merise samedi à 20h30
samedi également vous pouvez passer une
nuit avec tarantino et oui c'est
possible et ce sera la maison de
l'environnement à magny les hameaux au
menu pulp fiction django unchained
boulevard de la mort c'est samedi à
partir de 18 heures voilà notre édition
est à présent terminé merci de nous
avoir suivis je vous retrouve donc la
semaine prochaine c'est mercredi en
direct à 18h 30 d'ici là profitez de
tous les lieux culturels que nous avons
sur notre territoire à mercredi